The Better Angels was conceived in black and
white from the very beginning.
It was just the way that I felt Lincoln existed.
Lincoln lives in black and white and I didn’t
want to see him in color.
The reason why we thought it was appropriate
wasn’t purely for aesthetic reasons but
also to remove the romance of frontier life,
you know, what we imagine with the coonskin
caps and the muskets, the Lincoln log cabin.
It could lean towards Disneyland or something
like that.
And so we were after austerity and starkness
like you would have in a Bresson picture or
a Carl Dreyer picture.
And because especially and the frontier life
plus Lincoln on top of that, there’s a lot
of sentimentality that you could lead into
or, you know, just the tropes of just the
Americana patriotic story.
So yeah, we wanted a bit more integrity to
the film than the cliché’s that could have
happened.
We wanted the film to be a sensory experience.
It wasn’t just to be a Wikipedia article
about the facts and information of Lincoln’s
life.
We wanted people to walk beside him, labor
with him, cry and laugh with him and black
and white abstracts everything to turn it
into icons.
With color the image is much busier.
There’s much more to take in.
There’s more specificity to it.
Black and white immediately abstracts things
and makes symbols out of it so that man or
woman suddenly isn’t as specific.
They suddenly can turn more almost into the
image on the bathroom sign, you know, it’s
man and woman as a whole.
It gives you a generality in the best way.
In addition to the abstraction black and white
provides the production design.
You know it helped them immensely because,
especially with the limited budget we were
dealing with.
Immediately when you see black and white you
feel like you’ve been transported into the
past.
And so, you know, 20 percent of the art department’s
team was accomplished purely by muting the
color.
Not to say that their job was then easy after
that but it definitely gave them a leg up
I feel and they would agree.
You know, the first thing if you say you’re
going to shoot black and white is everybody
is worried for you.
Black and white has a stigma that’s attached
to it.
People view it as a disadvantage in that you’re
limiting your audience, your financial prospects
and categorizing your picture as something
that it may not be.
You know if you shoot black and white people
immediately think art or they immediately
think serious.
And so if someone is to consider black and
white for their project I guess I would say
the heads up that I would offer is that they
need to be prepared to fight for it and lobby
for that.
Unless they’re just surrounded by a fantastic
group that’s immediately encouraging and
doesn’t feel that there’s any risk.
Schindler’s list I think made like 400 million
dollars or something.
And so if the story’s there, the performances
are there it will connect people.
And connections are not in color or in black
and white.
They’re invisible but just as real.